hello there this is steve kaufman again
last little while have been posting
about multilingualism and have got some
you know different kinds of responses I
got a excellent response to the video
where I spoke in 10 languages recently I
had a discussion here where I said that
the present economic crisis could lead
to a decline in the prestige of English
as a language because so much of our
present economic system is is based on I
would say english language institutions
you know free market principles which I
of course I do believe in adam smith
wrote well nations which is kind of the
the cornerstone of that economic system
but for the last long while the world
has kind of been dependent on the US
market for a lot of products a
tremendous consuming market but a lot of
that consumption is based on debt
tremendous debt the extreme example
being people who were encouraged to buy
homes that they couldn't afford and and
I think there's there's perhaps a
realization that that a world economy
based on this engine which is fired by
debt that some people may want to take
another look at that I am not in favor
of massive government regulation as a
solution I think to some extent the
economic crisis was building up and and
if it hadn't been the subprime mortgage
problem in the state something else
would have burst the bubble with real
estate prices you know inflating
everywhere with you know the price of
oil all of a sudden spiking after having
hung around the twenty thirty dollar
mark for so many years I mean there was
something strange in the world and it
had to be it had to be adjusted and so
they just became one of the commenters
on my blog said no
that the you know the economic crisis
was caused by the greed of the
stockbrokers and it didn't matter
whether they spoke Chinese English or
Spanish so therefore the economic crisis
is not going to affect the prestige of
English sure is not going to cause a
nifty decline I don't think that
commentator understood my point it's
it's all about prestige French was very
prestigious in the 19th century early
19th century in places like Germany and
front and and Russia was the language of
diplomacy it was well established it
reflected the tremendously dominant
position the French had had right up
until the time of Napoleon and then
perhaps for some years after that so
attitudes can change and right now the
overachieving parents in Taiwan or
Brazil other or wherever they want
through children to go to English
kindergarten I hope that people will say
yeah English is important there's no
reason why more people can't speak
English as a Second Language and at the
same time speak another language in
other words curry encourage children to
learn more than one language and if non
english speaking people can learn
English then English speaking English
speaking people to learn other languages
and so it's not to say that we're going
to get rid of English it's just that
that the idea that that everyone must
learn English English is the only way we
are going to communicate internationally
I think that model does it is practical
and as one of the commentators pointed
out it that it's going there's a lot of
momentum behind English on the internet
and scientific communities and so forth
it's very practical to have one language
and so I think that will remain but I
think it can be can become quite
prestigious again and hopefully it can
be considered quite normal to speak more
than one foreign language so if you're
not an English speaker the first
language is english but then maybe
Spanish or Chinese are or some other
language of entry
doesn't really matter what I did another
commentator said you know we're going
away from multilingualism because so
many languages are threatened but I
don't think every little language has to
be protected I mean that doesn't make
sense I think a lot of the serve
diversity emphasis is misplaced we have
seen in in all of the major countries of
the world that minor languages in those
countries have disappeared does it
really matter if predictable person
speaks language a rather the language be
I mean if it makes sense to maintain
those languages fine if it doesn't it
doesn't so where people have been
successful at reviving minor languages
like ebru which wasn't spoken really
that much for thousands of years or or
well she's making a comeback and I know
they're trying very hard to bask and
many other languages that I don't know
but good for them go for it but that
doesn't mean that every single minority
language in the world has to be
protected according to some moral you
know requirement I'm all in favor of
doing it if there's enough people who
want to speak the language and at link
you know one day we would very much like
to teach Cree and other Aboriginal
languages because that's of interest to
me that's part of our sort of unique
heritage in Canada that that we have all
all of these different Aboriginal
languages most of which are disappearing
and it would be nice to try to maintain
some of them but because it's the only
if there are people interest in doing
it's not it's not something that's
morally required we get far too much
moralizing about things that aren't
really very moral at all so
multilingualism yeah which language is
your honor it's entirely up to you i
think obviously if you have english
chinese and spanish you've got a lot of
the world that you can communicate with
people in india do speak English to a
large extent I gather but
you could add to your ability to
communicate with people you learn Hindi
so that's those are some of the thoughts
on so I haven't given up on the idea of
encouraging people to to speak more than
one language and I think it I don't
believe that that people lose the
ability to learn language when they get
older and I'm i know that i myself I'm a
better language learner today than at
the age of 63 then then I was when I was
15 no question because I know more about
it I know how to do it I know the kind
of attitude I know how to get my brain
more attentive I know that I need a lot
of input in the language and if i can
find interesting input and if I focus on
interesting input i can I can power up
in the language pretty quickly I know
that when I speak the language I don't
worry about making mistakes I'm just a
much better language learner at 63 than
it was at 15 however if we can get the
children who are quite prepared to learn
anything and are curious and haven't yet
been discouraged from learning by our
school system if we can offer to
children stories content of interest in
two or three or four languages expose
them rather than testing among the
subjunctive in grade four or or
requiring them to write tests or
multiple choice questions in French or
whatever language the school decided to
teach I mean that's also self-defeating
because most of those kids at least in
Canada they're going to graduate from
high school unable to speak French so it
doesn't matter what they got in French
and grade five it doesn't matter at all
it's a complete waste of time it's there
purely to amuse the teachers have a
serves no purpose far more useful it
would be far more useful to give them
stories to listen to and read I think a
system like link is ideal they can
develop words and phrases from the
reading they go into flash cards you can
make a little more child friendly with
music and games and they just play in
different languages expose them to
different languages and and at some
point if they are interested in learning
a language and they'll do it but at
least expose them to the fact that there
are many ways of saying things
many different sounds many different
structures don't worry about that the
his whole business get about getting
things right I mean I speak languages
very well I make mistakes all the time
it doesn't matter when I'm corrected on
these mistakes of course I'll be a
little more attentive next time and it's
possible that i will eventually start to
get those things right but the main
thing is to communicate and so we need
to fundamentally change language
learning should not be test oriental it
should be communication oriented it
should be fun it's not something where
you about to get hit over the head if
you got something wrong so if we can do
that with kids and if we can interest
them in two or three languages not in
order to measure their performance but
in order to let them enjoy these
languages that I think we can go a long
way towards creating a more multi
lingual world so there you have a look
forward your comments